and how is Geo changed your lives
she's made it more fun it's okay
look at her hair Tiffany yeah she has a
son yeah
[Music]
oh my God
look over there you're making your TB
debut on CBS mornings yay is she looking
right at you
here's mommy over here
she is
here she is
she is she's talking to you yeah that
was not gassy that was a smile it was
Gia what's your favorite Robert De Niro
movie
which one do you like
the one in the delivery room we're on
the star yes you're the star that's
right okay this is my last question
you're the only one in the room who can
answer this at this particular moment
the best thing about Bob De Niro is
how much he loves his family
that might make me a little teary-eyed
that's nice